C'est incroyable ! Vous êtes déjà plus
de 200 000 à me suivre sur ma chaîne,
le cap a été franchi hier en fin de journée.
Et c'est allé très vite ! Il y a quelques jours,
je voyais la barre des 100 000 abonnés approcher
et je m'apprêtais à vous remercier.
Aujourd'hui, vous êtes deux fois plus nombreux.
Je vous adresse donc
deux fois plus de remerciements.
200 000 mercis pour vos pouces bleus
et vos messages de soutien et d'encouragement
qui chaque matin sont pour moi
une source de motivation.
Alors certains aimeraient des vidéos
un peu plus longues.
J'y réfléchis, on verra après le
confinement, pour le moment je me
concentre sur ces "capsules de déconfiné"
et sur l'écriture des prochains numéros
du Monde de Jamy ! Vous pouvez d'ailleurs retrouver toutes les "capsules de déconfiné"
en cliquant à gauche
et si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné
en cliquant à droite.
Encore une fois, je vous remercie d'être
chaque jour un peu plus nombreux et ça va très vite.
Je crois que je vais faire une capsule de "déconfiné"
sur la vitesse de la lumière.
Allez, à bientôt et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés, mais on reste en lien.